[Music]
amazon
show starts by making me immediately
stare directly into the sun animated or
not i started watching this with all the
lights off in the room and now i need
new retinas
superhuman evasion training i'm supposed
to learn to
[ __ ] roll away from a guy who can
shoot lasers from his eyes or
control minds or kick a goddamn school
bus to the moon
in an alternate reality where white
house guards need to be prepared to deal
with superhuman combatants the simple
concept of closing the gate between
vehicles seems to have gotten past these
two
along with anyone who has a fake id or a
dunkin donuts perks card for that matter
are you gonna be gone the whole time
all freaking week two all of matt's
spring break who gets two weeks of
spring break
and if there's a school that does i hate
you and i'll send you anyways
the boy is obsessed with the beatles
being obsessed with the beatles any time
after 1991
he stared down his demons and he
why don't i just make some hot cocoa
cheer up my sweet boy
this is supposed to be condescending but
hot cocoa is delicious and steve doesn't
make him follow through with this
promise
we were supposed to be inside i should
have never
trusted the flood calculations of a
clone clone shaming
also this smurfs reboot went a little
too gritty for my taste refreshing
kind of tickles and it's wasteful
they've been pelting them with zero
effect for 30 seconds now so why keep
going
your tax dollars are work am i right
this john ham cameo has been right there
watching how bullets don't hurt them and
he still takes a shot
kind of feel he deserves whatever comes
his way at this point
[Music]
i would give this a sin for war woman
and the immortal both doing three-point
landings
but martian man essentially does a
one-point landing so i'll take one back
so that's the two and then you subtract
the one and then you know what forget it
i hate math just
addison cool we've got fish guy stretchy
groot discounts wonder woman batman
wolverine and flash
and chroma keyset intern also superhero
posing instead of immediately getting to
work did you come here to fight or
audition for legendary
i wouldn't normally move so fast hiring
michael cudlitz to do a russian accent
and i love michael cudlitz but based on
the fact that steven youne lorne cohen
lenny james chad l coleman
and siniqua martin green are also in the
show feels like there was a walking dead
cast quota that had to be met
mahler twin thinks punching through this
wall would be easier than punching
through this window right around the
corner
you're welcome sassing those who are no
longer present we can take it from here
too dangerous for you throwing someone
straight up into the air is not the same
as getting them to safety
this is pretty much like getting thrown
out of a 12-story window because the
building is on fire sure omniman catches
them but nowhere was the scheme agreed
upon prior to the immortal tossing them
like clay targets at a skeet shooting
range
i had him but i wanted him to think he
was going to fall to his death because
that's how i have
fun evacuation complete now we can cut
loose and focus on taking these brutes
down
according to my interpretation of heart
of darkness by joseph conrad
the guardians of the globe may just as
well fall into the category of
brutes with the mahler twins i purport
that war woman's evocation of the
guardians will in this instance fall
short of addressing
the underlying moral and ethical
questions one must ask regarding the use
of superhuman force in the battle
against the ever-present and would-be
forces of evil
also she said evacuation this teamwork
makes the dreamworks segment of the
guardians of the globe handling the
steroid-enhanced blue man group might be
inspiring but it makes no sense
first green ghost drops them into
pavement they've already shown they're
stronger than at which point martian
bland hunter wraps them up for
containment so flash
boredom can land a few non-effective
punches then they let him go
why apparently so fish dude can free
them and also maybe soak them with
water at which point bruce plane can
drop a couple bombs on them and
shira can pool host them on top of each
other which i guess
ends the battle this is such a stupid
game plan i'm giving the show 15 sins
just for insulting our intelligence i
used to change your diapers kid
there's nothing going on down there i
haven't seen before the often overused
i'm your mom and i've seen your genitals
cliche
that being said she's not nearly
concerned enough that her son's reading
something called seance dog
my mom called me reading seance anything
that would definitely be grounds for a
discussion at least
and yes i know the science dog reference
but your reference doesn't outweigh my
sheltered childhood damn it
you should be overjoyed to see your
parents
passionately expressing their love for
each other no he shouldn't
and nor should he have to i don't know
the story behind why the high school is
called reginaldville johnson and i don't
care
i just know it's awesome long live carl
i can't believe the guardians of the
globe let them get that close to killing
the president
william would be invincible at tv sins
what kind of schedule is this
mark has three free periods every day
and apparently no classes on friday
even in this reality the school system
sucks you're such an
omni maniac way to root for the underdog
big fan of the yankees aria william
thinks a superhero with a high success
rate isn't cool i don't even watch
baseball but if every time the yankees
won a game it prevented a catastrophic
loss of life i'd probably root for them
as well
quit playing games i know you're crazy
about me vanity
no man has ever run away this fast after
being kicked in the balls oh you want to
run away but nature dictates that you
must cower in the fetal position for a
while first
millions of miles from here out in deep
space
is to planet viltrum expositional
fathering
exposition that's when i met your mother
the dialogue suggests that this scene is
depicting omniman saving debbie but it
looks more like he's threatening to drop
a car on her
also sho should get credit for not
making his weight over 200 episodes to
meet the mother just to have her die 30
minutes later but you made me think of
all that [ __ ]
so i'm gonna send you anyways canada
t-shirts that say canada on them
instead of how do you like my t-shirt
jehosha he is not getting hold of
superpower because mark is flying
shirtless and shoeless this far
up in the atmosphere and while his
nipple should be a detention and ready
to cut some
glasses all i'm saying
no one hears this or even mentions the
damage the next day
you're much better off if you relax that
muscle from time to time
use the momentum you're building to
carry you forward
these flying lessons go on for all the
some time could this have just been a
montage with a survivor song playing
over it
you know you spend your whole life
trying not to pee your pants so
letting go peeing your pants on purpose
it's
next to impossible it is not or i mean
so i've heard
are you questioning me it seems like a
pretty aggressive turn for omni man to
go from loving to abusive in like
20 minutes but foreshadowing has to
foreshadow i guess
titan's superpower appears to be an
easily defeated candy coating can't
blame a guy for trying to move unsold
merchandise
true but you can call bull on this guy
having an already tailored suit that
fits mark perfectly
sorry about the yard how does no one in
this neighborhood know that the grayson
house has superheroes omniman just takes
off from the roof at any given time and
mark makes human-sized gopher holes in
the backyard
i love my boring powerless everyday
run-of-the-mill mom
and i love my [ __ ] son the mother's
day conversation i had with my mom
somehow makes it into this episode
even if this ball could have found the
perfect momentum to not escape orbit and
somehow avoid any high terrain
at this speed it would have completely
disintegrated from the friction
also this is an incredibly negligent
game of catch everything else aside from
the fact that omniman is encouraging
this makes his turn to villainy not so
surprising
you actually are
invincible roll commercials or since i
guess this is streaming roll
next thing the algorithm picks for you
so you can't escape the sweet sweet
embrace of never-ending content
flows right off the tongue huh rolling
the credits here is confusing there's
like a whole 10 minutes left so
is this a 37-minute long cold open or a
10 minute mid credits scene either way
i'm excited to see what the next 10
minutes hold so i can finish this thing
off with all the good feelings
completely intact
denver is toast show never explains why
a villain who thinks a biplane would
provide the best thrust to
weight ratio for a jetpack has such a
serious vendetta against denver
oh man take me with you kids no
nikki you know guardian's business is
too dangerous for human children
it's also dangerous to leave children
hanging around abandoned buildings like
this one
does green ghost keep that pill in her
pocket that seems like an item that is
too important for a pocket designation
duckwing he may be the hero this city
deserves but he's not the mallard we
want right now
this mountain looks remarkably similar
to the one invincible threw the baseball
through
a little too similar well this
interesting turn of events is pretty
cool and i love this shot of red rush
fighting so hard he breaks his own hands
while punching omniman this all occurs
in the last five minutes the rest of
this episode
was pretty by the book but not in a way
that made these characters endearing
enough for me to even lament their loss
also this last five minutes has more
dismemberment than an entire saw film i
might have to watch spiral after this
for a palette cleanser
why why
because modern television is addicted to
cliffhangers that's why
you ain't cool unless you pee your pants
seniors go vows to our newest domain of
nifty delights and behold commercial
sins
oh and subscribe immediately so the
order goes click sub simple as that
oh actually watch the video jesus i
guess i need to make a flow chart
commercial sentence go now you're not
even gonna be here are you
not even supposed to be here today it
starts with one of you then
principal wiggins barfed on a lumberjack
that was sitting next to him
mayor grundy barked on his wife's tits
this is gonna be a little awkward
for both of us you see there's a certain
thing that happens between normal
healthy people
it's called chemistry it's kind of like
peeing your pants on purpose
what if peeing your pants is cool
consider me
miles davis hit me what
hey joey did i not tell you just to do
it i'm telling you guys do it
hey hey i'm your little brother joey i'm
telling you something i know what you
said i ain't doing it
who the hell are you i'm uh
i'm batman okay you're an animal
yes there we go you're a tiger you're
totally the tiger
you're great darkwing